and as you know my wife's about to give
birth to our first child congratulations
thank you very much and i i
um
you know we mentioned alexander
solzhenitsyn earlier yeah and one of the
things that he did and he he kind of um
he turned a lot of people off in the
west when he came from the soviet union
he went to america and he was perceived
as sort of lecturing americans about
their moral decadence and and um
i i'm not someone who's
i'm not an outsider here to tell you how
to run your country and run your life
i'm one of you now yeah i'm here and my
children are going to live in this
country and that's why i care deeply
about what's going to happen in this
society so
all i'm trying to do is remind people
of the things that are underpin
the value the values the freedoms the
prosperity that we enjoy here they
didn't fall out of the sky john as you
well know they come from
centuries of
ideological discussion of war people
have bled
to make this country as prosperous and
as free as it is and i think we owe it
to ourselves to not forget that and to
remember the value of everything that
that that's been created here
these are not accidents it is not an
accident that russian people like sergey
brin
have to leave the soviet union with
their family and go to america and
that's where they start google it's not
an accident that people have to flee
china and russia and emigrate and build
their businesses and create the things
that they create elsewhere these are
non-accidents the west is not more
technologically advanced by virtue of
some kind of historical misunderstanding
there are reasons for that right and of
course part of that reason is western
countries have been dominant in the
world but another part is the system of
government and the way that we do
business in the west has facilitated
that
and
uh i don't want us to lose that and i
don't want my children to to live in a
society that falls behind you know uh
this this is one of the big concerns i
have uh with many people in the west is
they
uh we've been so successful in the west
we've been so comfortable in the west
that we forget that at the end of the
day
life is a competition
and there as we talked about last time
when you interviewed the first time i
made this point people in russia and
china are not sitting around doing
identity politics as i said at the time
they're getting ready and now you're
starting to see the sergey lavrov the
russian foreign minister talked only
days ago about how the purpose of what
they're doing in ukraine is to push
america out of eastern europe and it is
to end the american global dominance in
the world that's what people want and
make no mistake about it they're coming
for what we have and i've tried to make
this point to people over and over and
over again
we don't live in some magical
rainbow-colored world in which everyone
wants to live happily and and trade and
whatever yes that's part of it but there
are a lot of people in the world who
just want what we have and they're
coming
our prime minister deserves a lot more
credit for his framing up of the very
things you're talking about he's talked
about an arc of autocracy
and we need to be alert to that and it
this is what's so valuable about what
you're saying because you understand
what autocracy is like you can see what
we've got and why it's worth fighting
for
i i feel that very strongly i think it's
really important
and
you know one of the things that i think
we
it's very difficult not to take for
granted things to which you've never
experienced an alternative if you've
always lived in a prosperous democracy
how it's like the sky
what you don't expect the sky to fall
down upon you right in the same way you
don't expect democracy to end you don't
expect your freedoms to be curtailed but
we've seen even over the last two years
that uh
that
um
softness that we've developed and that
comfort
causes us i think to be
vulnerable uh we are so attached to to
safety and comfort and stability that we
will throw away our rights
and freedoms when push comes to shove
and that worries me you touched on the
fact that it took years centuries and
bloodshed and a lot of deep deep
thinking and what have you
uh to to develop the institutions of
freedom in the west we're now very
cynical about our leaders that's
dangerous when we become cynical about
the institutions that's even more
dangerous i had a searing moment seven
or eight years ago i um through a a
charity i was involved with embedded
myself in a tertiary education
institution in myanmar the old burma
and after i'd been there about three or
four days
i was about to leave
it was really noticeable many of them
they saw me as some sort of quasi
authority figure you know i'd been
something in a western country and
they're a bit wary of me
the sort of natural leaders in a class
came up to me afterwards you could tell
they were the natural leaders
and those spokesmen
uh a young man looked me in the eye and
he said
in terms of great exasperation we'd just
like to ask you
we think the generals that are
tragically wrong are going to open up
we'll get some democracy
and he said how do we build a democracy
how do we build
a system of elections
and what have you that work how do we
build a justice system how do we build a
welfare system how do we build an
education system how do we
build a fund plan for infrastructure
i thought
these are such big questions and all i
could say was it took us years centuries
to do it in the west
but we could throw it all away far too
quickly
well i i think that's true we could do
but i
also have never been more optimistic in
the last few years than i am now it
could be just
the the upcoming fatherhood is is
forcing me to take an optimistic view
which is extremely unnatural for me both
as an individual and as a russian but
i
wonder
whether
i've been very surprised by the west's
reaction to ukraine
very pleasantly so john i when the the
invasion happened francis and i my
co-host sat here and and we talked about
live or about
what was happening and
i said many things which have turned out
to be correct i said some things which
we are yet to see if they're correct and
i said some things which haven't turned
out to be right for example i said
nato's over
i don't think that's true anymore we've
seen a strength of response from the
west that's been unexpected now we can
quibble with you know should germany
have sold off or closed down their
nuclear power plants probably not right
and i've been saying this for years
should they have made themselves as
reliant on russian oil and gas as they
have no they shouldn't but generally the
reaction from the west has been far
stronger than what i expected i don't
know if you were surprised by it very
much so and like you delighted yeah the
greatest danger is we drop the ball get
bored and back off yeah so we haven't
done that no we haven't done that but
there's a long way to go there's a long
way to go but germany paying a very high
price at this point
very impressive and a left of centre
government with a green foreign minister
saying we've got a double defence
expenditure yeah that's extraordinary
well it's the wake up call perhaps that
the west has needed so i'm optimistic on
that i think on the cultural stuff we're
starting to see shifts you know i don't
want to get too too deep into the weeds
of the culture war but i've said from
day one that i thought the trans issue
would be what broke this whole thing and
i think slowly but surely you're
starting to see that as you see waves of
people who've transitioned because they
were encouraged to uh and now regretting
it tragic stories by the way john these
are people who've mutilated their own
bodies and now coming back and by the
way look we've had a ton of trans people
on our show who deserve to be treated
respectfully who deserve to be uh enjoy
every opportunity and freedom in life
just as all the rest of us do
but some of the excesses of that
ideology not the people but the ideology
we're now starting to see the
consequences of that about which we've
been warning for some time you have the
cure bill case here we had the kirkbelt
case but there's thousands of people
like kira behind that as well you've got
to remember
and you're starting to see them pop up
now and hopefully
you know we can stop all this craziness
before it gets too late and before the
numbers just become astronomical but you
know we're starting to see
enough pushback against some of these
accessories that that
at least the pendulum is slowing perhaps
maybe even starting to swing another
direction and so my concern is that we
don't have a swing back because there is
a risk always that if you antagonize
people along racial lines
if you antagonize people along sexuality
lines you end up with a position where
we actually start to roll back some of
the advances we've had and and instead
of going well look maybe the trans
ideology has gone too far we've got to
protect our children
from being
encouraged to transition in one way or
another people start to actually go well
this whole lgbtq thing and gay people
all of that gets thrown out with the
bath water got to be careful so that i
think is actually one of the concerns
for me as well as we adjust and and our
culture starts to shift perhaps back
somewhat or in a different healthier
direction we've got to make sure we
don't over swing as well
so i'm starting to see some positive
moves on that side of things as well uh
so i'm optimistic
we've got to be optimistic john we must
be optimistic and uh of course i you
know one of the reasons i wrote the book
is i want people in the west to wake up
and to recognize the the tremendous
value of what we have here but i also
have to say you know i hope it's your
children and grandchildren and my
children and grandchildren who are the
ones who are building that better
society and if we
take responsibility which we should do
for making sure that we are educating
our
children correctly which we haven't been
for quite a long time if would they
understand history not just british
history or colonial history but history
john history
history means context it means you
understand not only what the british
empire was doing in the 18th century but
also what the russian empire was doing
in the 18th century and what the arab
slave traders were doing while the
western colonial powers were engaging in
the horrific transatlantic slave trade
that history if we can teach our
children that if they can understand the
context i think there's a very real
chance that the west can prosper again i
couldn't agree more because he's really
hit on something that strikes me as
really important here
who says slavery is wrong
where did that idea come from it was
endemic in just about every culture and
every society across the world and we're
right here in the city
where it was determined by a culture
that it was wrong
and a massive investment was made in any
not just in this country which is the
most powerful on earth at the time
but in obliterating it everywhere else
but that part of the story is not told
it's contextualization
so now we've got a move to d statue i
understand in edinburgh um
uh
the uh livingston you know the famous uh
african explorer an abolitionist
on the basis that when he was 10 years
old effectively a slave labour i suppose
he worked in a cotton factory and the
cotton would have been produced by
slaves
where's the contextualization that's the
point you're making that is the point
i'm making i have a whole chapter about
slavery in the book and i talk about my
grandfather being taken a slave laborer
to germany the fact that as i told you
my great grandfather who was in the
gulag as the engineered remember we
talked about this earlier yeah he served
his sentence on completely spurious
grounds of 10 years and he was kept in
the camps for another three years
because he was needed he was a slave and
this was in living memory right so we
shouldn't pretend that slavery um is in
any way unique to the west it's an awful
awful thing john
but every society has engaged in it
throughout history and that's the
context for which we need to look at
ourselves uh it's easier for me being a
dark-skinned immigrant to talk about it
which is one of the reasons i read the
book because i think there are plenty of
people in the west who disagree and
criticize and critique some of these
cultural movements that we've seen but i
think as an outsider i have perhaps a
little bit more leeway and i can give a
bit more context that people aren't
necessarily aware of because we've been
guilt-tripped we've been guilt-tripped
about our past you you don't have any
responsibility for things that happened
400 years ago and i don't think anyone
should feel guilt because of the color
of the skin i think
the reintroduction of racialized
thinking into our societies is one of
the worst things that we could do to
ourselves that's why i've been pushing
back so strongly against her i don't
want my black friends to be treated
differently because they're black and i
don't want my white friends to be
treated differently because they're
white and the fact that we now live in a
society where it's become acceptable to
say oh you're a white man or whatever
and that is somehow a dismissive thing
that like that implies whether that you
have some sort of lower value in the
hierarchy of who's allowed to express an
opinion or whatever i think it's
outrageous i think it's disgusting and i
think it needs to end and i am
determined uh that as a result of the
conversations that we have on this show
and you have on your show and the
broader leaking of that into the public
domain because i think a lot of people
are fed up with it frankly john
i am determined that that ends we've got
to go back to the point and i i sort of
tweeted a quip about it the other day i
said i i i have a dream that one day um
our ideas will be judged on their merit
as opposed to the color of our skins we
should be able to say what we think
and irrespective of where we come from
that is the western idea that is to me
why the west is worst preserving it is
the only part of the world john in the
history of the world where that idea has
actually been embraced
ever
ever
and you know there are challenges with
building multi-ethnic societies like the
ones we have in the west that they are
very differently in other countries as
you know in china it's very different in
russia it's the same most of the rest of
the world operates on a very simple
basis there is an ethnic group that is
the dominant one of that society
everybody else is some sort of
second-class citizen
and that's the way that it is we are
trying to do better here we're trying
desperately and it comes with
difficulties and it comes with
challenges and it comes with problems
but we are desperately trying and we
should be encouraged and celebrated for
that not talked about like we're the
worst people in the world because we're
not
your concern that people live in freedom
and dignity and so forth shines through
give us a taste give us a teaser you've
got a book coming out in july
what should we know about it so that we
can decide whether to go and get a copy
well uh i talk a lot in the book about
things that you probably don't know
about uh and i relate them to what's
happening
in the west i mean one of my
central themes in the book is to relate
my family history my own experiences the
experience of my parents and my family
whether that was being born in the gulag
or my grandfather being exiled from the
late soviet union for his views on
afghanistan or whether it's other things
that most people in the west have
probably are not familiar with um and
how they relate to what's happening here
i talk for example about where political
correctness comes from do you know no
but it comes from the soviet union
it was invented in the soviet union and
had nothing ever to do with any sort of
politeness or respect for other people
political correctness was a way of
saying to people comrade
this is factually correct but it's
politically incorrect and what it meant
was it was inconvenient to the party
line
and many of the things that are now
happening have an explanation and i dig
into some of that in the book as well
and you know one of my
i suppose my main
argument is
and you'll like this because of your
religious uh beliefs i suppose is
we have to learn gratitude again for
what we have and i think the only way to
do that is to appreciate how unique it
is how unusual it is how extraordinarily
unlikely what we enjoy in the west is a
garden in a jungle quite and we're
letting the weeds take over the garden
we're in danger of letting the jungle
encroach right and the only way to do
that is the garden has to be protected
john it has to be guarded it has to be
nurtured it has to be watered and
appreciated by the people who walk in
our garden and enjoy the fruits of it
[Music]